jetzt kommt jetzt jemand der nicht zu
diplomatisch ist ich will sprechen über
die Kollateralschäden genau und und ich
habe ja gleich mein anfangsstatement
hier ziemlich emotional vorgebracht und
und hat gleich reagiert aber ich denke
das Problem dass wir haben Herr kortis
dass wir zwei verschiedene
wissenschaftsauffassungen haben ich
glaube wir können das mal auf den Tisch
bringen zwei verschiedene Menschenbilder
ganz offensichtlich ja ich habe auch
diese ganze Zeit begleitet mit mit einer
kritischen Haltung der Medizin gegenüber
und habe dabei möglicherweise auch Dinge
gesehen die vielleicht andere nicht
sehen ja
tatsache ist wenn ich sage verschiedenes
unterschiedliches wissenschaftsbild oder
Menschenbild
das was ich jetzt in den letzten drei
Jahren gesehen habe und zwar von Beginn
an war eine eine ganz offensichtliche
Ausgrenzung des psychischen und sozialen
aus Menschenbild ganz klar und da und
darunterkrankt die Schulmedizin seit
Jahrhunderten das ist kein neues
Phänomen wir sprechen in der
Wissenschaftstheorie von
Minimalismus und von Reduktionismus
Dualismus meint wir grenzen Geist Seele
und Körper ab wir trennen sie
voneinander genau das haben wir gesehen
in den letzten drei Jahren massivst ich
habe von Beginn an ich kann mich noch
erinnern April 2020 in der Tiroler
Tageszeitung in kleinen Bericht darüber
geschrieben mir war sofort klar hier
stimmt was nicht hier wird was
Wesentliches ausgegrenzt wie eine
Lockdown machen oder Schulschließungen
machen nämlich das Wesentliche dass uns
Menschen ausmacht wie ich weiß es aus
der psychoonomologie ich bin Forscher
ich beschäftige Hüter Verbindung Psycho
und Immunsystem ich weiß wie übermächtig
psychisches und soziales ist wenn es um
Immunsystem geht und wenn wir Menschen
auseinander bringen dann ist das eine
ganz lineare ganz kühle Rechnung wir
denken es sind Maschinen aber es sind
keine Maschinen sind Menschen und wir
Menschen auseinander bringen dann
kriegen den immunsuppressionen dann
haben die in sozialen Schaden und dieser
soziale Schaden ist für meine Begriffe
und da haben wir einen unterschiedliches
Bild wahrscheinlich für meine Begriffe
weit gefährlich als das Virus und es hat
ja auch gezeigt dass das Virus so
gefährlich nicht ist es betrifft da ich
bin kein corona-leugner ich mag den
Namen schon gar aber ich sehe den Ernst
der Lage überhaupt keine Frage bitte für
eine ganz begrenzte kleine Gruppe eine
riesige Gruppe die geschützt gehört wo
dieses viele Geld an Impfkampagnen das
jetzt ausgegeben wird längst hätte
verwendet werden müssen in den Maßnahmen
jetzt wird es schon wieder verpulvert
jetzt müsste man sich vielleicht um
longkowit kümmern auch da ein
interessantes Thema weil da bin ich auch
absolut anderer Meinung wie Herr Korte
also das heißt wir haben es mit einem
riesenschaden und Medizin Desaster zu
tun weil wir psychisches und soziales
weggesteckt haben oder weggespalten
haben von Menschen und ein eine
Katastrophe angerichtet haben und wenn
es zynisch klingt auf der anderen Seite
bin ich auch froh darüber denn jetzt
kann sich auch was verändern jetzt wird
aufgearbeitet und zwar jetzt wird
aufgearbeitet und dieses
Verantwortlichen ich bin davon überzeugt
die müssen auch die Verantwortung tragen
und das wird auch vor Gericht sein
der Fragen wird auch direkt einmal Herr
Korte fanden sie denn überhaupt die
Schulschließungen richtig wenn ich Sie
richtig verstanden habe fanden sie dir
auch nicht richtig
nur weil ich wissenschaftlichen Daten
viel Gewicht einräume dass ich ein
anderes Menschenbild habe ich bin
Neurowissenschaftler der sich durchaus
mit den Effekten die die Umwelt die
Menschen auf die Psyche haben auf unser
Lernvermögen sogar auch auf das
Alzheimer Risiko ist einer meiner
Forschungsgebiete unter zeigt sich das
eines der Risikofaktoren davon
Einsamkeit ist das haben wir gerade zu
Lockdown Zeiten enorm praktiziert und
auch da war ich immer kritisch nicht
gegen die lockdown-maßnahmen weil ich
auch gesehen habe man muss unterscheiden
ob einen Virus einem bestimmten
Maßnahmen auf zwingt die man für richtig
hält und wie man die dann durchzieht
also zum Beispiel bei den
Schulschließungen habe ich mich von
Anfang an kritisch geäußert weil ich
gesagt habe wir müssen ja abwägen gegen
das individuelle Risiko was die Kinder
haben was tatsächlich was ein schwerer
Verläufe angeht niedrig ist auch nicht
Null aber niedrig und die durften nicht
weiter zur Schule gehen und genau mit
den Konsequenzen die wir gerade gehört
haben da haben pubertierende ihre
Pubertät verpasst wir haben noch
kleinere Kinder die die hier ihre
sozialen Umfeldes beraubt wurden und das
muss man jetzt im Nachhinein auch
tatsächlich haben wir auch gerade gehört
kritisch auch aber angeht hat Herr
Lauterbach ja auch schon zugegeben dass
das unnötig war also dass die
kita-schließungen die Frage ist ob man
das damals hätte wissen können man hat
ja auch Leute die da arbeiten die älter
sind die durchaus ein Risiko haben und
es ist auch nicht eine kleine Gruppe wir
haben allein fast zwei Millionen
Krebspatienten in Deutschland die alle
in Risiko darstellen wir haben in
Kindergärten auch ältere
Kindergärtnerinnen die eben zum Teil
auch Diabetes haben also das ist schon
so ganz einfach ist die Entscheidung
auch nicht aber ich habe von Anfang an
mich dafür stark gemacht dass man die
Kinder Kinder sein lässt und versucht
das einigermaßen einzudämmen zum
Beispiel Schulen mit Maske hat sich
gezeigt klappt eigentlich relativ gut
gibt auch Infektionen aber alle man sich
relativ gut schützen man war nicht
bereit wenn man über Geld redet wofür
man Geld ausgibt aber nicht bereit
Lüftungen dort zu installieren die Geld
gekostet hätten wenn ich mir gucke wie
viel in verschiedene Maßnahmen zum Kauf
von Lufthansa und sonst was aufgewendet
wurden aber 5 Euro 50 in die Schule zu
stecken das geht nicht bleiben wir noch
einmal bei der These von Herr Schubert
also die kita-schließung haben nichts
gebracht die Schulschließungen haben
auch nichts gebracht also Stand der
Forschung die kita-schließung auf jeden
Fall nicht jetzt gerade wurde gesagt die
Masken in den Schulunterricht auch
nichts gebracht wir haben es von Beginn
angesehen dass Schweden an einer Weg
gegangen ist ich möchte dass das immer
wieder betont wird wir haben ein
natürliches Experiment ein soziales
Experiment ist die Schweden durchgeführt
haben und sie waren erfolgreich aber es
wird immer unter den Tisch gekehrt so
wie diese Daten immer unter Tisch
gekehrt werden die offensichtlich gegen
dieses narrativ gehen von einem
killer-virus das nur mit Impfung
beseitigt werden kann ja und Herr Korte
sie haben trotzdem vorhin gesagt auch
Kinder sollen geimpft werden und auch
erwarten und für erwachsene Kinder Sinn
von Covic nicht betroffen
0,5 betroffen also Entschuldigung wie
denn jetzt sagen Sie das doch bitte mal
von Virus gibt schwere grippale Effekte
es gibt Entzündungen im Gehirn es gibt
herzkranzentzündungen auch bei auch bei
Kindern die kann man nicht
wegdiskutieren da kann man nicht so tun
als wenn Kindern nichts passieren kann
dass wir so als würde ich sagen die
brauchen die brauchen sich morgen ich
hoffe sich die brauchen sich morgen
nicht mehr anschnallen weil es gibt auch
nicht viele Kinder in Deutschland die
dann halt durch einen Unfall sterben ich
also ich meine das ist einfach eine
Risikowahrnehmung die so nicht kann
stimmt was sie ja glauben glaube ich
eigentlich sagen wollen ist dass man die
gefahren dort deutlich übertrieben hat
und das hat sich tatsächlich auch
bewahrheitet wissen Sie was man getan
hat man hat
die Politik die Schulmedizin und die
Medien die die verantwortlich sind in
diesen letzten Reihe an die haben die
Kinder in die Tonne gehauen psychosozial
wir haben sie terrorisiert tyrannisiert
und dann wundern wir uns dass sie solche
Krankheiten haben ich sage dieses
Psychologen sie können mit psychischen
und sozialen Belastungen alles in
entzündungsphänomen machen alles was sie
in ihrem Buch beschreiben kann alles
posttraumatisch Belastungsstörungen sein
das wissen Sie ganz genau was sie aber
nicht berücksichtigen ist dass man
natürlich in all diesen Untersuchungen
Kontrollgruppen hatte die unter den
gleichen psychosozialen Bedingungen
aufgewachsen sind und die andere
Phänomene zeigen ich wundere mich dass
sie das Kontrollieren man hat ja nicht
ohne Kontrollen gemessen insofern ist
das in diesem Faktoren genau die
psychischen Faktoren sind heute Lockdown
gleich ob sie sich infiziert haben oder
nicht und viele gerade bei long-covit
haben einen leichten Verlauf gehabt die
waren nicht schwer krank wie sieht es
gerade auch bedeutet hat man die Angst
erfasst in diesen Studien also ich hätte
das auch gelesen man hat auch die Angst
an Seite des order gehört Meter zu und
zeigt sich im übrigen auch entlang ihrer
These auch bei den Menschen die sich
nicht infiziert haben also auch da sieht
man dass die Pandemie stärker zu
Angstsymptomen geführt hat die
Depression hochgefahren hat und andere
psychiatrische erstörung hervorgerufen
hat auch ohne Infektion
Syndrom bei den Kindern wird kennen das
ja mittlerweile wenn ich das ist kein
Post aber Corona man Vielfaches erhöht
wenn man halt einmal infiziert waren
also jetzt den Menschen die schwer krank
sind am longkow wird abzusprechen dass
sie krank sind oder dass sie nur durch
gar nicht automatische Störungen
Psychosomatik ab ich werde das nicht ab
sondern ich sage man kann das nicht auf
ein Phänomen reduzieren natürlich werde
ich keine Psychosomatik als
Neurowissenschaftler abwertend weil ich
weiß wie das Gehirn auch soziale Signale
interpretieren kann sie haben das eben
mal selber gesagt wie Signale aus der
Umwelt auch dass sie Immunsystem so
primieren also unterdrücken können auch
das ist mir bekannt darüber forsche ich
im übrigen auch also dass mein
Forschungsgebiet damit das bei ihnen
einsickert das heißt darüber was aus und
psychologischen Mitteln
wenn ich einmal einen gemeinsamen Nenner
von Ihnen beiden herauskristallisieren
darf dann haben sie ja auch gesagt die
kita-schließungen waren rückblickend ob
man das jetzt besser hätte wissen können
oder nicht falsch sie sagen auch die
kita-schließung waren falsch den
gemeinsamen Nenner hier dann ist jetzt
meine Frage wen könnte und sollte man
denn dafür verantwortlich machen Herr
Schubert weil das ist ja hier so
anscheinend noch zu betonen wenn wir
sagen dass die kita-schließungen falsch
waren und die Schulschließungen falsch
waren dann ist das nicht ein
Kavaliersdelikt dann ist das nicht
irgendetwas ach dann haben wir das getan
und es war wohl ein Fehler absolut
sondern wir haben hier dass die
Gesundheit von Kindern langfristig über
Jahrzehnte gefährdet das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt wir wissen aus der
psychology dass wenn sie Kinder in so
eine Situation bringen und ihr sie an
Entwicklungsstörungen in
Entwicklungsstörung bringen und wir
wissen ja nicht mal was da passiert
konkret Lebenszeit die verlieren konkret
Lebenszeit das heißt die sterben früher
wie viele Jahre oder kann man das gar
nicht vorstellen das kann man sagen es
gibt Studien die zeigen wenn wenn Kinder
im ersten oder mit Kinder und
Jugendlichen ersten 18 Lebensjahren
sechs und mehr schwere Belastungen
mitgemacht in ihrem Leben dann haben Sie
einen lebenszeitverlust von etwa 20
Jahren das ist ganz schön viel also wir
reden hier von wirklich ganz was
Wichtigem und wenn sie sagen wer soll
hier oder wie soll das zur Verantwortung
gezogen werden ja es wird aufgearbeitet
so wie immer diese Dinge aufgearbeitet
werden müssen solche Traumatisierungen
die mit der Gesellschaft stattgefunden
haben und es sind ja nicht nur die
Kinder wir reden jetzt in diesem Fall
von den Kindern wir haben die
Jugendlichen natürlich wir haben genau
wie Herr Kotte das auch noch mal gesagt
hat es ist hier etwas passiert das kann
man nicht einfach sagen jetzt gehen wir
zu einer zur Normalität wieder über das
geht nicht dass das da werde ich mich
auch absolut dagegen wehren es ist noch
mal um es klarzustellen Reduktionismus
und Dualismus in der Schulmedizin und
die Untersuchung von denen sie reden ich
bin überrascht dass Sie auch
psychologische Forschung betreiben bei
sich in Braunschweig dass sie Interviews
gehen dass sie Fragebögen austeilen dass
sie neurobiologisch forschen mit
psychischen
Methoden das ist mir jetzt neu und dann
habe ich Ihnen vielleicht Unrecht an
wenn Sie das tun ich frage ja auch
einmal den Ökonomen in der Runde weil
Corona hat hier auch ein
gesamtwirtschaftlichen Schaden muss das
auch aufgearbeitet werden unbedingt noch
eine Bemerkung zu Herrn Korte
laut Studien der Deutschen Gesellschaft
für Kinder und Jugendmedizin ist das
Risiko zu ertrinken 5 oder 10 mal größer
in Deutschland als an covis zu sterben
also diese Infektionszahlen bei Kindern
und Jugendlichen das sind so niedrig
dass er davon eine Gefahr zu sprechen
für Kinder und Jugendliche ist ab
evidenzbiert wissenschaftlich absolut
nicht haltbar ich habe zwei Bücher
zugekaufte Wissenschaft geschrieben und
das ist ganz massiv auf Fake
Wissenschaft basiert gewesen
und der eine Studie veröffentlicht hat
die hane Büchen war aber es geht genau
ihr Fachgebiet also die lockdowns haben
unsere Wirtschaft dramatisch geschädigt
und haben dafür Gegenzug die Profite der
großen Konzerne dramatisch steigen
lassen jeder Tag Lockdown mein
Milliardengeschäft die großen Konzerne
und dahinter stehen Milliardäre ich war
Investmentbanker sieben Jahre das war
ein mega Geschenk inwiefern uns
praktisch erklärbar zu machen inwiefern
war ein Tag Lockdown ein Geschenk für
Konzerne ein Geschenk des Himmels
war weiß ich nicht oder aber hier im in
Berlin Einzelhandel wird stillgelegt und
Amazon Jeff bestes Bild zum reichsten
Mann der Welt und das gilt aber nicht
nur für ein Einzelhandel nicht nur für
Amazon auch die die kleinen Gastronomen
die kleinen Hoteliers die werden
getreten die großen Ketten werden
überlegen überleben das zeigt schon
Klaus Schwab sagte schon in seinem Buch
voraus es war ein massives Interesse
eigentlich der große Teil der
Großindustrie lockt dann zu hart so
schlimm solange wie irgend möglich jeder
Tag wenn ein Milliarden Geschenk sie
sehen das an den gewinnsprüngen der
US-Konzerne die sind in den Himmel
gefahren beispielsweise nehmen wir mal
Deutschland da wird wahrscheinlich nicht
gewesen sein dass jeder Tag Lockdown
hurra war unser rückreiz sind ja nicht
die Konzerne sondern die
mittelständischen Unternehmen die
Familienunternehmen wir leben von den
Hidden Champions in diesem die haben
definitiv darunter gelitten wir haben ja
kein Amazon hier oder Facebook oder die
Konzerne wir haben auch große und kleine
bei der die HOGA in Oberbayern deutsches
Hotel und Gaststätten Gewehr wird man
Gastronom erzählt man die
Großgastronomie
schweinebrockenkissen am mai die
bormillionen Umsatzrückgang das macht
uns gar nichts super weil dann werden
die ganzen kleinen grautere die gehen
alle pleite und dann kriegen wir die
Locations kostenlos also auch in
Oberbayern an die großen fressen die
kleinen und das war nicht die
Weltkonzerne die großen fressen die
kleinen auf allen Ebenen die großen
Konzerne fressen im Mittelstand diese
lockdowns war ein Frontalangriff auf
unsere Mittelstand auf die
selbstständigungsbahn eine einzige
Katastrophe und da waren auch massive
Interessen dahinter je mehr Lockdown
umso besser umso mehr können wir die
kleinen fertig machen
wie blicken sie wirtschaftlich auf die
Lage ja ich würde sagen wenn wir die
wirtschaftsmittel dieser vielen
Milliarden nicht gehabt hätten dann wäre
der wirtschaftsgau der vielleicht jetzt
die nächsten Wochen Monate folgt
vielleicht früher gekommen wir haben ja
seit dem GAU 2728 ich glaube das müssen
sie sehr gut das ganze nur aufgeschoben
also die Notenbanken haben Geld gedruckt
das gibt es kein Morgen und irgendwann
wird es dann mal ja runtergekommen jetzt
hatten wir Corona Corona haben wir
übrigens auch Trump zu verdanken also
nicht alles war gut
[Musik]
und und vor allem auch oder oder
vielleicht was positives
korrigieren umgekehrt Bein hätte ohne
Corona nicht gewonnen weil Trump eben
auch viel gemacht hat ich glaube der hat
ein paar Millionen mehr Amerikaner auf
dem Gewissen durch die Art und Weise wie
er umverantwortlich umgegangen ist und
es hat beiden auch geholfen weil aus dem
Keller heraus einfach den Wahlkampf
machen konnte er wäre nicht mehr
physisch in der Lage gewesen diesen
harten Wahlkampf durchzustehen also
meine These ist ohne Corona wäre Trump
ein zweites Mal ins Weiße Haus gekommen
also das eine aber das andere um die
These noch mal weiter zu spinnen wir
haben das sehr viel Geld gedruckt und
haben da wirklich ja jetzt noch mal in
der Finanzkrise und haben jetzt noch mal
ein stimmlos draufgelegt und draufgelegt
so und jetzt holt uns aber das ganze ein
weil wir nämlich durch Corona auch Güter
runter genommen haben auf der einen
Seite pushen wir viel Geld rein und
Drogen Geld und durch Corona wurde
wurden die Wertschöpfungsketten
zertrennt also weniger Güter und durch
dickhubbling was von Trump und da kann
man dann schon ein bisschen in das Thema
was ich dann mache wir müssen noch
dafür weil das wird dann rund und
vielleicht hilft es dann auch dass das
auf den Punkt zu bringen also durch
dieses decubbling wurden noch mehr Güter
Weg gemacht und jetzt sind alle
überrascht alle Notenbanker das war man
viel Geld reinpusht und Güte rausnimmt
dass wir Inflation haben und die
Inflation kann man nur noch begrenzen
indem wir bremsen die Wirtschaft
abwürgen also und stehen knallharte
von Wertschöpfung genau dass man sich
eben von China Weg trennt nur noch mit
guten Handeln treibt und da werden wir
noch das ein oder andere